tenemos este problema sean z 1 y z 2 2
números complejos distintos y z igual a
1 - por z uno más t por zeta 2
estos son importantes para algún número
real te conté mayor que 0 y menor que 1
esto también suena importante dices y
argumento de w denota el argumento
principal de un complejo no 0 w
entonces y nos dan varias opciones y la
idea es que una o más de ellas pueden
ser correctas vale entonces tenemos que
ver cuáles son correctas ahora como
pequeño recordatorio vamos a ver que era
el argumento de un número el argumento
del número complejo era el ángulo que se
formaba al unir el origen con este
número complejo y ver qué ángulo se
hacía con el eje real déjame pintar un
plano complejo para para para recordarlo
entonces y aquí tenemos nuestro eje real
y acá tenemos nuestro eje imaginario y
por aquí tenemos un número complejo z
número complejo z
entonces para determinar el argumento
unimos el origen con z es un poco chueco
un poco más bonito sería algo así
el origen con z y nos fijamos en el
ángulo que se forma con el eje real
entonces si este de aquí se llama
digamos si estoy aquí es igual al
argumento de z bueno después de este
pequeño recordatorio vamos a ver qué
pasa con cada uno de esos incisos vamos
a empezar con el inciso a y lo que vamos
a hacer es encontrar cada uno de estos
sumandos y luego vemos si si nos da z 1
- z 2 vale entonces vamos a calcular
primero cuánto es z menos z uno las
normas de z menos z 1 y vamos a ver qué
nos queda entonces necesitamos la norma
de z menos zeta
ok lo que vamos a hacer es sustituir el
valor de z por esta z de acá entonces
nos queda la norma de aquí z uno por uno
es z 1 z 1 - t por z 1 este z 1 tz uno
más t por z 2 t por z 2 ya eso tenemos
que restarle z 1 - z 1 muy bien vamos a
ver qué nos queda z 1 se cancela con z 1
eso está padre y lo que nos queda es
pues este por z 1 con signo negativo y t
por z 2 con signo positivo como los dos
tienen te déjame factorizar la t
entonces nos quedaría t x 72 menos z1
muy bien entonces eso de ahí es el
primer sumando vamos con el sumando que
está en morado
entonces ese de ahí es z menos z 2 y
misma idea sustituimos el valor de zeta
que es z 1 - t por z uno más t por z 2
es estoy aquí menos y ahora hay que
restar se está 2
- z 2 muy bien otra vez aquí tenemos
algo x té y algo x té así que lo voy a
factorizar entonces pongo primero z1 z2
z 1 - z 2 y a eso le voy a sumar
le voy a sumar te por z 2
172 menos z 1 ok quizás convenga
factorizar esto un poco más aquí hay z 2
- z 1 aquí hay z 1 - z 2 entonces déjame
cambiarle el signo a este mira lo voy a
hacer así lo voy a poner y lo voy a
cambiar el signo este de acá para que
nos quede z 1 - z 2 y aquí voy a ponerle
menos t por z 1 - eta 2 z 1 - z 2 estoy
haciendo esto para poder factorizar este
z 1 - z 2 y este de acá vale en estos
dos suman 2 entonces eso nos quedaría
igual a datos igual a 1 - te suena la
norma de 1 - t
este por z 1 - z 2 z 1 - z 2 muy bien
entonces ya tenemos el primer sumando y
el segundo sumando vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando los juntamos entonces si queremos
hacer la suma nos quedaría este el verde
citó la norma de t por z 2 - z 130 1 más
la norma de 1 - t la norma de 1 - 1 -
este x z 1 - z 2 ahora aquí tenemos
norma de un complejo pero observa que
aquí hay un real multiplicando este
número complejo y los números reales
pueden salir de la norma siempre y
cuando salgan con valor absoluto
entonces vamos a hacer eso vamos a sacar
este y este 1 - t con valor absoluto de
cada uno de estos suman 2 entonces esto
nos queda igual a entonces este te sale
que da valor a su valor absoluto de t
eje x la norma de zeta 2 - z 1
y aquí tenemos que sumar tenemos que
sumar en color morado el valor absoluto
de uno menos t 1 t multiplicado por la
norma de zeta 1 - z 2 pero observa
sabemos que te es un número real que es
mayor que 0 entonces valor absoluto de t
éste y además sabemos que te es menor
que 1 entonces uno este también es mayor
que 0 por lo tanto su valor absoluto es
uno menos t muy bien pero más aún de
este término y este término de acá
estos de acá son normas de dos números
complejos que son 1 el negativo del otro
entonces tienen exactamente la misma
norma sale osea aunque éste va hacia un
lado y éste va hacia el otro con
respecto al 0 de todas formas tienen la
misma magnitud la misma norma vale
entonces la norma de zeta 1 - eta 2 es
lo mismo que las normas de zeta 2 - z 1
y ahora si podemos juntar todo esto que
sabemos para ver que estoy aquí es igual
a la norma de z 2 - z 1 este lo estoy
factor izando con este y aquí en un
paréntesis en donde estamos factor
izando podemos poner el valor absoluto
de t que este y a eso sumarle el valor
absoluto de 1 - t que es uno menos t
simplemente estoy factor izando y
aprovechando que la norma de un negativo
es igual a la norma del número muy bien
pero ve esto está padrísimo aquí la t se
cancela con el menos t y nada más nos
queda un 1 y de esta forma nos queda una
vez la norma de zeta 2 - z 1 que es la
norma de zeta 2 - z 1 y con esto
concluimos que el inciso a el inciso a
en efecto es correcto muy bien entonces
le voy a dejar hasta aquí en este vídeo
en los siguientes vídeos vamos a ver si
b c y d
también son correctos o no